tomorrow what what do you make of this
latest statement from the conservative
party they won't investigate this until
there has been uh an official Complaint
that's right they are not going to
investigate this because no complaint
has been made and that is their their
policy at the moment but certainly uh
this story has caused quite a few
ripples across Westminster Daniel corski
was one of the can the candidates to be
the mayor of London the Conservative
candidate to face Sadiq Khan in the
election next year now he has been
accused by a woman called Daisy Goodwin
who is a successful TV writer and behind
dramas like itv's Victoria she says that
she met him in Downing Street 10 years
ago when he was an advisor to the then
Prime Minister David Cameron she had met
him at an event and she'd been invited
to Downing Street to discuss an idea for
a TV program based on government policy
she had a meeting with Mr corski she
says and at the end of it she says that
he touched her breast and she asked him
what are you doing and says that he was
embarrassed she did not mention it at
the time but she has spoken about it
since although she did not name
as that advisor she has written in a
piece for a newspaper today that she's
decided to go public because he is now
in that race and she feels a
responsibility she says to stop men in
powerful positions at behaving in that
way now Mr corski categorically denies
that this happened a spokesperson for Mr
corski gave us the following statement
it says in the strongest possible terms
Dan categorically denies any allegation
of inappropriate behavior whatsoever he
says that it didn't happen now he is on
a short list of three people to be the
Conservative candidate after working in
Downing Street he went into business and
the tech sector and he was he had the
endorsements of quite a few senior
people in the conservative party but I
think the pressure will be on now on Mr
corski I spoke to a senior conservative
this morning who was one of those
publicly backing him who told me that it
feels sustainable now and they would
privately urge Mr corski to back out of
the race we have not heard any more from
him other than that statement from his
spokesman he was reportedly taking part
in a public hustings last night when the
news came through and he left I think
some decisions will have to be made soon
about how he continues to be in this
contest but yes the conservative party
we understand not currently
investigating any complaints because no
complaint has been made to them
okay tomorrow thank you very much